dude what if we make guns gay yeah and
then people won't want guns anymore wow
people are upset at four now because
it's a rainbow Ford in the commercial
and it does like uh traditionally
colored Ford like if AR-15s were like
like a rainbow and then people are
jumping on my hands yeah I ain't
shooting that yeah no I'm I'm boycotting
all AR-15s from now on it's just these
yeah okay come paint these yeah you
can't paint these fish no rainbow and
then we wouldn't have gun problems
anymore just make the guns gay it's like
Winchester is is trans yeah make the
tracers rainbow yeah yeah have the gun
make like a noise when the bullet comes
out like yeah
and people like oh man they ruined it
they ruined our [__] guns